forensic police at the scene of the
second mass shooting in Serbia in two
days this time in the town of dubona
south of Belgrade Witnesses recall the
moment the attack happened
I could hear people running I'm not sure
how many people were running away but I
saw many youngsters
I looked out of the window but I didn't
go out suddenly I saw people carrying
the wounded
it happened at a football pitch armed
with an assault rifle and handgun the
shooter opened fire from a moving car
killing and injuring several people
after a Manhunt that lasted several
hours police arrested the suspect on
Friday morning many people are trying to
process the loss of people they know
I am shocked my daughter is taking
sedatives we couldn't sleep all night
they grew up together from preschool to
primary and then Secondary School
on Wednesday a teenager shot dead
several children and a security guard at
a school in Belgrade police say the 13
year old used his father's gun and had
planned the attack for a month hundreds
of people took part in a vigil at the
school in honor of the victims
this is a tragedy for the whole nation
it's not only a tragedy for the families
this affects our whole society
president Alexandra vujic has declared
three days of national mourning and
promised to toughen gun control laws
we will conduct a complete disarmament
of Serbia penalties for owning an
illegal weapon would be much more severe
almost double
mass shootings are rare in Serbia the
last occurred in 2013 when a war veteran
killed 13 people one of the biggest
questions police are trying to answer is
what prompted two young men to carry out
these violent attacks and why now
Al Jazeera